[Music]
we're headed out to horse Island
the Peabody has been in possession of
this island since the early 1970s
we're currently building a teaching
Pavilion in partnership with the
architecture school
[Music]
he said well how about if you guys could
build a lab building for us a new
building that would be off the grid
this is the first project of the new
regenerative building Lab at the Yale
School of Architecture which is a sort
of advanced version of the Yale building
project
[Music]
it was sort of a crazy time to graduate
so it worked out really well to have
this unique but temporary project to
work on the seminar started as the
regenerative building seminar as a
spring course last semester turned into
a design phase and then ultimately now
into the construction phase of the El
Peabody Coastal Research Center
the idea of this building is to provide
a sort of hub for researchers who are
visiting doing work for classes coming
to study parts of the island but of
course it's also a bit of a balance
this is a Preserve in a way and we want
to preserve it because otherwise the
research that you can do in here is not
going to be that exciting if we've
damaged the ecosystem too much design
for disassembly is the idea of using
screws Fasteners which you could remove
so theoretically you could take this
building apart the same way that you put
it together and because we prefabricated
so much of the building on West Campus
how we were going to make those
components and then disassemble them and
package them to be able to rebuild them
really efficiently here where we're
lacking a lot of our tools and equipment
so when the buildings ultimately
disassembled we can reuse all of the
materials again I'm pretty confident
that we'll have it ready for use in late
spring
every day is is a fun New problem to
solve and a lot of variety a lot of
different things certainly beats the
monotony of saving at a computer all day
long so it's it's really fun there's one
of the guys on the crew says this is the
best day of my life and he says it every
day so I think that's a good sign
[Music]